today is World Food Day and we at the
Council of the European Union have
decided to celebrate by having some of
our colleague taste some of Europe's
most special food items let's see how
they got on it looks gross
yeah I knew it
so haha smells how do I eat them I just
[Music]
should I use my fork or I can't get it
out
tastes like garlic that's it
and I think that garlic sauce is really
nice so yeah not bad
that's good what do we have here
ah this is this was like a desert
barbecue sauce looks like jam or
something
it's Opie's really it's sweet and sour
it's more sour no sweet oh my god
[Music]
I don't smell anything so while it's a
raw meat - oh no what exactly is this
it's like tomato now that I know that
it's from the inside of the head of the
pink I wouldn't try it again it's great
use of the meat we have to use as much
as we can this is a traditional food
from my country no meat maybe Germany
this one looks like sausage stew or
something like that hmm
I could eat this every day very tasty
it definitely has curry in it and I hate
curry I'm not like a medicine it's not
disgusting it doesn't stink of this
[Music]
oh my god lemon looks like you're all
meat is actually pretty good all right
and this thing helps a lot
[Music]
it looks gross oh the smell so this is
stinky fish I'm sorry I've never tried
no thanks